okay do you think Jeff do you think the
Donald Trump made the right decision by
skipping the White House Correspondents
Dinner Oh something we're going to agree
on I do yeah absolutely [ __ ] who
give this [ __ ] I think here's why I say
so this is all about scholarships for
kids they take a lot of kids from poor
liberals from liberal colleges so
basically they're choosing him to
fundraise to create future generations
whether they're Horace - dinner is a
charity it's fundraisers for right for
journalists journalist young journalist
that's great I'm all for that but well
you know there needs to be a little
balance if first of all that's not a
charity is it always pisses me off that
everything at colleges are not a charity
either people you can give to your
Harvard as an endowment of 12 trillion
dollars you can write that off and also
it's a dumb thing the correspondence I
said how about you been I've been do it
yes I know you know I take Kardashians
go and from somebody some sitcom actress
and they don't air the scholarship part
of it I mean it is a scholarship dinner
which I didn't even know until the first
time that I went and I sort of even
soured on it even though I went because
you know quite frankly would sort of
store things you have Barack Obama you
want to go and see him do this in person
with but I went the year that Baltimore
was exploding and here we are at this
fancy dress balls okay and outside of
that hotel where we unbeknownst to any
of us while we were laughing at jokes
Baltimore was on fire like the road that
made me sound on it a bit I grew up joy
believing that journalists were supposed
to comfort the afflicted and afflict the
comfortable not hobnob which is
happening right yeah well cuz I could be
good me to picture the same day when
we're no longer going to the White House
Correspondents Association that's today
April 29th there going to be several
hundred thousand climate demonstrators
in DC so it will be something for all
those enough to do
[Applause]
those of using drones are an effective
weapon in the war on terror it depends
how you use them I mean that's sort of
like asking whether I think guns are an
effective weapon the war on terror you
can use them to do smart things using
stupid things mostly I think in the last
15 years particularly less eight we've
used them kind of stupidly you think
Obama I'm stupid oh yeah absolutely I
mean I won the one and only thing I will
agree with Michael Flynn on is that when
you look at the results of this
whack-a-mole approach to
counterterrorism we managed to take a
situation where we more or less double
the number of active terrorist groups
and then tripled the geographic spread
of terrorist groups you know I think
it's I think that that it's extremely
ineffective it's probably given more
strength to terrorist recruiting efforts
than anything else
partly because it kills civilians which
is some extent unavoidable in a war
obviously but also you know even the
terrorists have friends and relatives
and so on and it isn't people are oh yes
okay Charlie at what point do you think
a Republican leaders like Paul Ryan will
stand up to Donald Trump oh yeah that
was that was actually painful watching
Paul Ryan you know standing and
applauding well you know Donald Trump
was was laying out all of his spending
plans you know watching the vichy
Republicans you know you know showing
that the day we have been completely
taken over I mean you know the it's been
painful actually watch the absolute
capitulation of the conservative
movement and Republican Party to adopt a
Donald Trump I mean it's Alaska
hi but you know at some point then I'm
not going to not going to take you know
compete you taking the bullets for this
guy but I don't know you know this is
this has been the the rolling I've been
the rolling process of Ville of the last
year you know you have the full-out
collaboration it's like I like you mr.
Lord then you have the Vichy Republican
like you know well of like you know
partly alright or some of its appeals as
the Vichy Republicans were on Capitol
Hill all this time so operating and not
pushing forward with their agenda they
promised they would when they were let
down which agenda is that means 50 times
trying to vote to repeal Obamacare
wasn't enough maybe because I had the
power the purse I didn't use it they
didn't use it so now you have the power
of the purse your daddy's going to spend
out of the purse so you know we're done
what happened watching conservatives go
you know we have to be you know fiscally
conservative we have to be ideologically
pure and then they go and they embrace
well that would happen in which issue
were published by the Chito Jesus you
know and he don't have this like I don't
know Republican wrong but what is going
to happen with this budget fight I mean
it looks so much like Reagan defense
build-up we don't cut entitlements and
we have a big tax cut and of course
George Bush the first call that voodoo
economics and of course it did run up
the debt Reagan did run up the debt
that's undeniable those are facts it
just looks like that's happening again
do we just have amnesia about that
Ronald Reagan did not have control of
the purse look with the Tip O'Neill and
Jim Wright who could control the house
on cars well that's the way this works
when Newt Gingrich when Newt Gingrich
became Speaker he never even he he got
together with Bill Clinton and said we
are going to cut spending they did do it
and it did balance the budget I've got a
half rate all the taxes which is how
they down some budget but they they
raise taxes I mean that is how bill got
that right here which guy right it's got
no Republicans zero no and put the got
back to the 70 percent it was under
armed only will raise taxes back to 70
percent the other thing to thing that
worry I do
I don't think Republicans will ever turn
on Trump because Paul Ryan is made it
pretty clear that he is going to use
Trump's
right hand as he regulated to get the
things that
Paul Ryan wants Paul Ryan essentially
wants to repeal the 20th century he
wants to privatize social security if he
can cut Medicare cut Medicaid cuts is
Sam essentially throw the poor onto the
mercy of charities and churches turn
everything into a fistful of vouchers a
voucher for you to go to school which
you're not going have to pay for because
miss DeVos wants to privatize it a
voucher for you to buy health insurance
good luck if the voucher isn't enough
for you to pay for a policy that can
actually help you when you're really
anxious and that's Fistful of vouchers
strategy they can throw it on Trump
would say well from signed a and then if
you really want to bankrupt Social
Security it's are you kidding because of
the cadet C that's the biggest myth the
Republicans push so security is not
going to be bankrupt Social Security has
a service area versus you say that
because you want to privatize you going
that window as you've never done it the
Republicans have never wanted it to
exist
yeah seven look when we got to the night
maybe you don't want it to exist no I do
want it to get oh you do heck I'm going
to be on it but what good listen you how
much is our debt here what twenty two
trillion dollars 20 down under bond
Evers we know Bank and we added eight
what a trillion dollars to this the
point is if we bankrupt the country and
we are glad that you young carefully
given private is on having the deficit
and the debt he doesn't even talk about
the dead he doesn't even pretend to be a
fiscal conservative he basically said so
very stands up there and he's in effect
we're not going to touch any of the
entitlement programs join I disagree on
this he would wait you know those are
where we're going what raise yeah yeah
that's what but but you know he goes at
me suggest but will cut foreign aid or
we're gonna cut the national endowment
are anything in it because oh there's a
big big inning was not fine right with a
jewelers off you look in the budget yeah
it's complete magical thinking I mean
listening to Trump's speech a couple
days ago I was you know we're going to
dying industries will roar back to life
we will just unleash our dreams and make
it happen I thought whoa out of your
belly calm down
versity wait I know that's a big last
line for you slowing the rise of the
ocean it's not funny
well the fact that the oceans are rising
and getting not just warmer but more
acidic directly of course he did he did
make a start with the Paris climate of
course you know how hard that is to get
200 countries to sign on to something
and now your idiot is going to resent it
but yes you a minute sitting do it no we
didn't do it in the Tommy was in all
fifty eight years oh that's good okay
we're talking about carbon in the
atmosphere it took 200 years to get
there well then why would you say he
could do it he didn't say he's going to
said we're going to begin to slow the
rise of the oceans you're gonna add it
he did if you count guys your guy wants
to speed it up I mean this afternoon
this afternoon that one of the things
that Obama did that was very smart was
managed to get through the mileage
regulations that said that we would be
by the middle of the next decade be
having 15 averaging 50 miles to the
gallon or 54 whatever for cars something
that technologically we're completely
able to do without any problem I mean we
live in a world where say Norway has
announced that all cars will be electric
thereby within five years today
today it became clear Nordstrom's is
today today it became clear that the EPA
the APA was not only going to get that
not only going to take back the request
of the automakers take that pack they're
talking about taking away the one thing
that's really the California's
particular ability California is the one
state that has its own ability to
regulate pollution but Jeff they take
that away in general I asked this a bill
before we brought it up you know you do
believe in theory of course I'm guessing
of things that we can't see like germs
and out
god haha but but germs and atoms you can
see I would concede okay so then by that
logic global warming we can't really see
all the we see its effect until until
all I'm saying I'm a skeptic nada I
don't say hoax right what's he fix like
scientific to Bill this is the problem
as I see it is that too much politics is
infected all sorts of sectors of our
society including science I want the
science know what I feel when I hear the
term that's that ninety seven percent of
whatever scientists and it have reached
a consensus consensus bill is a
political word it is not a scientific
word there is pretty here is no wait
wait is there a consensus that the earth
is round it can be both whether there is
or not it's a fact you do understand
that the scientific method is that if
you do an experiment on hundred times
and you get the same results
99 times and I'm going to do it at 99%
here in senators what I mean right
here's what they mean
like when when Darwin published origin
of the species in 1859 it was many
decades before there was a consensus
about it because the other scientists in
the world were like well that's
interesting let's see if we can prove it
wrong that's how science works and after
many decades they were like well we
can't
Darwin's right and now we're at that
point with this in-your-face issue in
this case we were at a long time ago
yeah good in replicative reporting would
be some good investigative reporting in
the last few years has shown that Exxon
knew everything there was to know about
climate change by 1977 to 1981 their
scientists were telling their senior
management exactly how much it was going
to warm and their senior management was
taking it seriously they began building
their drilling rigs to come by the way
for the rise and Recoleta they knew
would come Rex Tillerson of Exxon is the
one who doesn't want to pull out of the
page that's right that the Exxon guy oh
he's the Mad Dog matter I will point it
thank you very much everybody
[Applause]